this camera on top of sunset station way
down in the southeast valley and there's
an airplane either taken off or
coming in for a landing it is a great
start to your monday temperatures are on
the mild side it's a great time to get
out walk the dog or take a little jog or
whatever 77's the official number out at
reed international much cooler 72 up in
centennial hills in sky canyon also 72
down at mountains edge in rhodes ranch
74 for seven hills and anthem air force
base you're at 80 same with sunrise
mountain a little bit warmer henderson
you're at 82 but the wind has begun to
die down we did see gusts upwards of 20
25 miles an hour over the weekend
nothing too outrageous 91 right now for
death valley
41 up in ely there are some clouds
scraping across the extreme northern
sections of the silver state i don't
think we're going to see any of that
down here and really not much wind it's
just the temperatures are going to be
warming up we're going for 100 today
that would be just a few degrees above
normal no threat to the record for
today's date at 110 but the eight day
forecast you want to take a look at that
in a couple of minutes actually just a
couple of seconds because i wanted to
talk about why the national wireless
service issues those excessive heat
watches and warnings they never used to
because the criteria were unattainable
and some lives could have been saved
they changed the criteria so that when
we get to near threatening temperatures
well heat is the number one cause of
weather related deaths in our country
more people die from heat than die from
hurricanes or tornadoes and floods so
when they issue watches and warnings it
raises awareness and hopefully we'll
keep better care of ourselves so here
comes the heat those clouds are for much
later in the week scattered showers over
the pacific northwest into the northern
rockies strong storms racing across
missouri and arkansas right now what was
tropical well it still is tropical storm
alex moving to the north of bermuda but
65 mile an hour wind is going to kick up
some beach current there but that is
expected to roll on into the northern
atlantic so we're going to roll on into
much warmer temperatures 104 tomorrow
106 wednesday 107 thursday tying the
record high of friday at 108 108 again
on saturday with a record high of 109.